oh hi it's chris kohler with wired com
and we just finished up the gauntlet of
e3 press conferences Sony just finish up
their e3 2008 media briefing uh Chris
Baker a little light on content from
Sony today yeah in fact they really set
the tone at the beginning when they said
look at how much we still had to release
two years into the original Playstations
lifecycle he is into the PlayStation
tues website which is pretty much saying
you know we may not have give the goods
this year but you know we we've got we
are we were planning a long term we've
just begun to scratch the surface of
what we intend to deliver for consumers
in the months and years ahead that is
kind of like what it sounded to me but
Sony did take this opportunity to shore
up their 2008 holiday lineup and remind
us all that great games like infamous
are coming up for ps3 really soon yeah
and they they made a real tentpole out
of a little big planet which is a really
innovative unusual game that really
relies on the game users to create their
own content and they in a really
inspired move they use little big
planets level creation tools to to tell
their their financials the sort of
boring dog and pony show that every
press conference has they turned it into
something really amusing and a really
great application of the game yeah and I
mean I could have watched a little big
planet for the entire 90 minutes at the
press conference myself but they did not
do it that way and they showed some
other games too began very light on
brand new game announcements Ratchet and
Clank quest for booty is a new game
coming to the PlayStation Network this
summer resistance the ps3 first-person
shooter is going to be on PSP
there was madd which probably probably
not up our alleys but you know the socom
franchise is enormously popular and here
is a not massively multiplayer but
enormously multiplayer shooter 256
players based on that so calm brand I
think that's going to generate a lot of
buzz yeah really interesting the idea of
doing a 256 player online shooter game
where you're all sort of organized into
squads of eight men but then there's
player persistence you can grow your
character over time which is what they
were talking about so uh but again you
know the fact they only showed a kind of
very early trailer of the game means
that it's one of those things that's far
far out in this holiday season we're
really looking at things again like
infamous motorstorm too and a little big
planet of course yeah probably one of
the big announcements with an immediate
payoff was about their video store which
is finally in place they have a few more
partners than then we'd maybe been led
to believe MGM Lions Gate and of course
so many pictures movies will be up on
there but the interesting thing about
the Sony Playstation 3 video store is
that it actually launches today and so
tonight if you turn on your ps3 can rent
movies from between three and six
dollars so you can buy them from between
ten and fifteen dollars download them
right to your ps3 and then what if you
want to take them on the go with you you
can plug in your PSP and copy the movie
straight over to that so maybe maybe we
won't have the the instant appeal of
Microsoft's Netflix deal where if you
subscribe to live and to Netflix you can
stream these movies for free but again
PlayStation is doing the the high def
content but Sony isn't at this point
they're they're really positioning
themselves as kind of the the centum
files consoles between that and blu-ray
one announcement that Sony kind of made
under the radar is that they are going
with one version of the PlayStation 3
going forward starting this fall it's
not going to have the playstation 2
backwards compatibility that some of the
current models have but it is going to
have an 80 gigabyte hard drive so if you
want a ps3 that plays all your ps2 games
go out and buy the metal
solid for bundle package now because
later this year that's not going to
exist anymore and tellingly they're not
putting all their eggs in one basket
continue to talk about the PlayStation
to continue to support that not dropping
the price of it either so they'll be
pushing that again this Christmas even
though it's what eight years old now
nine years yeah eight years old now so
Sony this year is really hitting those
hardcore gamers that Nintendo isn't but
at the same time no real big innovations
like Nintendo's new motion controller no
big casual games like Microsoft was
showing just a lot more of the same yeah
the message seemed to be you know we we
practice like a ten year life cycle with
our console so just trust us where we're
viable where we're in this for the long
haul you know we might not be blowing
you away this year but just whale next
year